[Applause]
thank you very much for inviting me
today I'm delighted to Be With You Dear
Mr Praises Mr first mayor Madame Senator
Mr Senator members of the European
Parliament
my uh dear members of the city assembly
of Hamburg I would like to welcome
welcome warmly welcome the honor citizen
of Hamburg Professor Otto and the deputy
Secretary General of the oecd and first
and foremost I would like to uh say
hello to all of you ladies and
gentlemen um just a few years ago
building this new uh hydrogen terminal
would have been Unthinkable but here in
Hamburg Harbor we see this has become a
reality and soon
uh it will be able to transform ammoniac
into renewable hydrogen and this will
make a big contribution to
decarbonizing one of the major uh
Industrial agglomerations in Germany
this will make Hamburg one of the very
first ports in the world which will be
able to import hydrogen in huge
quantities and in addition there are
manufacturers of Steel copper and
aluminium products who want
to be able to produce cleanly but who
huge who use huge amounts of energy this
will now be clean energy and proximity
to this terminal will be a huge
competitive Advantage it's worth looking
back at how and why we have managed to
achieve this result in record time when
I took office for years years ago as
president um the idea was that um
hydrogen would be able to replace fossil
fuels in shipping or in heavy industry
um and that was already a a a possible
serious possibility but there was one
thing still missing uh in order to make
that a reality and that was that
investors need
predictability uh they need a clear and
certain um Way Forward and that is what
the European green deal has been able to
provide the European green deal hasn't
just provided a clear uh forward looking
vision of making Europe a clean
continent and carbon neutral continent
but it set also a binding legal
framework which the European Parliament
and all 27 member states have signed up
to and this means that Europe's
political will is now clear and this
means that the world's biggest economic
block has been able to provide the
necessary certainty and predictability
which
investors need worldwide but something
else has also made this a reality in
February
2022 Russia invaded
Ukraine this war continues to be a
disaster for Ukraine
but it has all and it has also caused
serious problems to our industry you
will recall that before the war we were
highly dependent on Russian gas and
Putin knew that and built on
that
vulnerability but when at the beginning
of the war we came directly in to
Ukraine's Aid uh Putin tried to
Blackmail
through this uh
vulnerability he constantly reduced gas
supplies to the member states we were
able to resist and we did go through a
very severe energy crisis there was a
10-fold increase in prices but we were
able to break our dependency on Russian
fossil fuels we were able to diversify
our sources our friends helped us
for example the United States and Norway
and we have also managed to save 20% of
our energy consumption our citizens here
in Europe have reduced their consumption
by 20% we asked for 10% and we ended up
with 20% Energy savings the most
important
point is that we have first and foremost
U massively invested in renewable
energies the result of this is that last
year for the first time we produced more
electricity by wind and uh solar power
then from gas and this
year as the International Energy agency
is predicting this year for the first
time we will
produce more energy from wind and solar
than from gas and that is uh means that
it is clear for us that Renewables are
not just good for the climate they are
of course but they're also good for our
energy
Independence they are produced here they
produce create jobs here and they have
helped bring Energy prices down to where
they were before the war and we have uh
learned from Putin's blackmail and have
set ourselves new goals as of
2030 every year we want to be able to
produce
on a yearly basis 10 million tons of
clean hydrogen and we want to be able to
import a further 10 million tons this is
very ambitious but
achievable and doing this here what
we're doing here in Hamburg is a model
project for all of Europe and I can only
congratulate you on that
achievement
we are supporting this in a whole range
of ways we have the new auction system
of the European hydrogen bank and all
this means that the hydrogen industry in
Europe will get a uh will be greatly
stimulated Hamburg is very much in the
Forefront of all this and this is
against the backdrop of a a boom in
renewable energies in
2022 the growth in solar capacity was
50% as compared to the previous year in
2023 another 40%
increase uh developing solar energy is
happening well before the original um
planned Tim table uh in the runup to
2030 and in the case of wind power we
have uh speeded up the whole
authorization process for wind power
plants uh and this means that Germany
last year was able to approve three
times more onshore wind Parks than the
previous year the more cost effective
renewable energy we produce the easier
and better it will be to produce uh new
alternative energy sources for heavy
industry and for shipping and Hamburg is
very much in the lead to in this respect
ladies and gentlemen the European green
deal has set a framework and set the
course but as
previous uh speakers have said we will
only move forward if we can roll up our
sleeves and get down to work all of us
and that is exactly what the Hamburg
Chamber of Commerce and Industry is
doing it requires teamwork courage
determination and resilience and with
your per verbial farsightedness htic
farsightedness you have taken up this
opportunity I'm not surprised uh this is
the oldest uh Chamber of Commerce in
Europe and you have the experience uh an
understanding of the European green deal
you understood um the opportunities it
opens up not just towards climate
neutrality but the European green deal
is also about
growth the agenda
the Hamburg 2040 agenda combines
environmental responsibility with
Economic
Opportunity we have heard from you've
heard from experts you've heard from
International
organizations uh such as the OCD with
whom you have worked you have first and
foremost involved your businesses in
this process because Innovation is J
jobs uh Prosperity are all down to
businesses first and foremost most and
last but not least you have set yourself
clear goals it's very important to have
measurable goals because we all know
it's only what can be measured which can
will actually be put into practice
ladies and gentlemen our work is far
from over
2024 will be a decisive year uh experts
are predicting more geoeconomic tensions
from the Red Sea to the Taiwan Straits
and this
means that there are potentials for
Supply chains to be interrupted greater
volatility on the energy markets and
international competition will become
harsher these are the new realities we
will have to deal with and in addition
we have growing numbers of extreme
weather um crisis due to global warming
we Europeans must stick together as
never
before we will need to prepare and we
must be able to better prepare for these
realities let me come briefly to uh
number of two further issues firstly
energy infrastructure and secondly the
importance of artificial intelligence
for our competitiveness firstly on
energy energy price
need to fall further because they are
structurally higher in Europe than in
other parts of the world and that means
that we have to make the right decisions
for investment now in Brussels we have
already given the go-ahead for 166 new
infrastructure projects in the energy
sector um this ranges from um power
networks both on land and on on the sea
electrolyzers for hydrogen production it
covers transport and storage of CO2 but
it also covers the super grids these uh
extensive and and secure networks which
stretch across our whole con continent
these networks are managed with the aid
of artificial intelligence and they can
send the cheapest energy
to where it is most needed in
Europe in this way we can create a
strong infrastructure for our economy
secondly
digitalization as you are all well aware
here access to Innovative Technologies
is ever more important innovating in the
digital domain will help greatly improve
productivity when it comes to use of 5G
and faster assembly plants we can
increase production by 20 to 30% the
hamburger Port um plays a key role in in
terms of
5G um use and we can
see much greater potential still in the
future our
companies will
become increasingly dependent on how
well they can take on board artificial
intelligence in their everyday business
and uh activities and I know this is a
matter of great importance to you here
in the Chamber of Commerce and industry
it's not just a question of larger
companies but even more so in fact for
small and medium-size companies just to
take a few simple examples uh AI powered
chat Bots um in the case of uh companies
with relatively few staff they can help
improve customer service it's it saves
time and while the
bot is dealing with routine questions
over and over again your staff will be
able to deal with the really complicated
uh issues which need immediate attention
another example artificial intelligence
can reduce uh the inter interval um
between maintenance and optimize
production processes that applies to um
storage and to supply chains artificial
intelligence if used effectively in a
very pragmatic way can help uh provide
cost major cost benefits and that's why
it's very important to get down to work
uh on this issue one point which is of
key
importance uh is that Europe does have a
clear
competitive uh advantage in terms of
data we have huge data industry an
enormous wealth of data far more than
any other world regions we have the
largest industrial uh wealth of data
anywhere in the world um this data
accumulates but it's not used enough and
to use
this these flows of data with the aid of
AI can help us achieve great quality
improvements at EU level we're now
working in a very focused way to ensure
that smmes will have greater access to
these data bases it's not just a
question of uh access to existing AI
Solutions the ones
I've just mentioned already but it's
also a question of ensuring that we can
make Innovative leaps into the future
which will be of uh um worldwide
importance let me give you a few
examples when I began my term of office
in
2019 uh among the best five
supercomputers worldwide there was not a
single European example and we decided
to invest massively in this field 7
billion EUR to be precise now we have
four of the top supercomputers worldwide
are here in Europe Luma Lumi in Finland
Leonardo in
Italy Marin nostrom in
Spain and recently Jupiter in Germany so
what are we going to do now with these
uh supercomputers well there are a lot
of things you can do yesterday in the
commission College we decided that our
European startups that they must have
access to this computing power so that
they will be able to bring their AI
ideas to Market they will be able to
test them they will be able to further
develop these ideas and this means that
Europe will be turn into a Bastion of
high technology and if we can achieve
this it
will also have a huge impact in favor of
climate neutrality our topic for today
AI
applications will help improve
production um they will
also help for example reduce energy cons
consumption for lighting your premises
um they will be able to manage Heat
heating or ventilation
systems uh much more effectively AI
can develop Logistics Concepts which
will and in a way that can be constantly
updated taking account of traffic data
and uh weather data and find identify
the most favorable Roots so that's good
for the climate but it's also good for
your bottom line ladies and gentlemen
at the same time
we must recognize that the energy
transformation tackling climate change
will require serious efforts by our
citizens and our businesses a
willingness to change will be essential
but like any change of this kind it will
open up tens of thousands of new
opportunities for our citizens when
President Biden Biden talks about this
issue he always says that when I think
of the climate I think of jobs and he's
right let me give you a few examples uh
the number of uh people employed in the
Solar sector in
2022 in Europe increased by
39% to 650,000 and the forecasts for
2027 uh estimate that we should have
double that 1.2 million jobs what other
industrial sector could present figures
of that kind this is very
encouraging of course a lot of work
Still Remains to be
done and one point is I think
particularly important in this respect
uh if we want to achieve success and we
all do it will very much uh require that
we work in a United and harmonious
fashion politicians can set the
framework but it is up to business to
create Innovation business opportunities
and jobs we have to work very closely
together we in the European commission
have an
overview we have uh we are informed
about best practices uh right across
Europe be it's in terms of climate
change or artificial
intelligence and we want to collect
these examp examples of best practice
and share them with you and this is
something which which we hope that the
Chamber of Commerce of hamg will be
interested it has always been a has
shown a Pioneer spirit in this and in
other respects and I think other big
cities across Europe can learn from
Hamburg and its Chamber of Commerce and
industry but we in the European
commission not only can we share
experience with you but learn from your
experience as well good practice bad
practice all the things that we can
learn from and that is why at European
level we want to invite Chambers of
Commerce and Industry to regular
exchanges of experience let me send out
an invitation to you now today to that
effect thank you for this initiative and
uh I must say as I listen to what you
have to say I don't see any reason to
worry that we will fail to achieve our
goals I'm quite sure we will thank you
for inviting me to the beautiful city of
Hamburg thank you very
much thank
you